JENNY BROWN: This
week, we're talking
about the What-If Tool, AI
codelabs, and database basics.
I'm Jenny Brown, and welcome
to "This Week in Cloud," where
we serve you the
lowest latency news.
Last year, we introduced
the What-If Tool
for TensorFlow models.
And now, we're making it
available on AI Platform too.
You can use the What-If
Tool to gain a deeper
understanding of how your models
work under different scenarios.
Grab the code from the
post to get started.
Or, for a little more
guidance, this codelab
is a great place to start.
In it, you'll learn exactly
how to train models in Cloud AI
Platform, generate
predictions, and of course,
compare different models
using the What-If Tool.
Take an hour this week to
upgrade your modeling skills.
For a deeper dive,
@GoogleAI has published
a bunch of free guides
on GitHub to help you
learn about Keras and OpenCV.
We think it's the perfect
way for software engineers
who want a straight path
with no math to #ML.
So if you want a
comprehensive set of resources
and don't want to look
in multiple places,
@GoogleAI's collection
is definitely for you.
If you've ever
thought about running
a database in the
cloud, this article
is a great place to start.
You'll get a roundup of recently
published database solutions
from deploying the common IBM
Db2 in the cloud to migrating
an existing database to GCP.
There's even tips on
backing up your database
and how to add
features like tracing.
Go check it out.
If you want to read more
about these announcements
or see a full list,
check out the link.
Have any thoughts or ideas?
Leave us a comment or tweet us.
We'll see you in the cloud.